michael michael
where'd you grow up where you from
originally originally if you want the
truth
i'm from the hollywood hills oh you are
yeah
i was born in the hollywood hills but
that doesn't
keep me from ending up on skid row
if you want my story about how i ended
up here yeah
tell me about how you grew up first um i
i grew up well i had both parents
in the house my dad worked a lot my mom
was the primary
caretaker and and i had a there was a
maid who
also took care of me so i think i felt a
little bit
neglected but my dad made up for it in
vacations and and a lot of your parents
were together
yeah yeah but dad was working a lot
dad worked a lot and my mom for a while
was at home
and she would take care of me when i was
a little kid but as i
grew up and went to school she started
to work with my dad
had a family business that i thought i
was going to go into
but that didn't end up happening
but no no crazy abuse or anything like
that no that's the thing
there was no abuse yet there
were drugs in the house there were
pain pills in the closets and from
a very young age i started getting
migraines
and i remember it clearly i was on a big
bear trip
with my dad and i had a migraine
and we were in the middle of nowhere and
he pulls out
a little hill from his pocket says
this'll get rid of it
and i was really young but i remember
how it made me feel
and i remember what the pill looked like
and i found that same pill in a bottle
in the closet and
i started taking those because i like
the way they make me feel
and as a kid i was really shy socially
awkward
and i didn't know how to relate with you
know other people
and so when i took these pills
i could just let all that go and i just
i felt great it's interesting
yeah and where did that
lead well for through high school
it didn't really cause any any problems
but as i went to college i got good
grades
but i really i started having severe
depression
when i went into college and like
i just i couldn't go to class i couldn't
do my work
and i remembered these pills and so i
started taking them
every day and stealing them from my dad
i'd go home
and then bring a bunch of percocets back
to the dorms
and keep on taking them and then i
realized i had to take
more to to feel the way i needed to to
progress
and to pull a 3.1 gpa
which for some people was great and for
some it's terrible but for me
i was getting by and my parents were
happy
and you know i hadn't told them about
this abuse but i started
because of these pills i started
experimenting with
other types of drugs uh ecstasy
and methamphetamine and i liked the ops
you know i liked the
the downers so i realized i liked
i liked pills and eventually
my dad caught on he noticed that his
whole prescription was missing
and he was yelling at me about it and i
broke down and told him
look yeah i have been taking your pills
i'm sorry i'm not gonna do it again
and he excused it then it happened again
i started stealing the pills
again and realized that when i didn't
take them i felt sick
and so my parents sent me to
sober living which did not work out
i ended up relapsing in there and
basically i heard of a friend that i
used to hang out with
that he had something called black tar
heroine that was cheaper
than pills and so i went to his house on
purpose
knowing that he had this drug and he was
smoking it
and he offered me a hit and that was it
no more pills for me it was way cheaper
and i could just call him
up anytime and so that happened
and smoking it wasn't getting me to
where i wanted
um you know and there was one day when i
met a connect of his who would shoot it
up
with cocaine and he didn't have
any foil to smoke it on but he had a
needle
and i was sick and he had a needle of
cocaine
and heroin and he injected me with this
and my life was never the same after
that i was chasing this high
and what i had to do to get money first
it was
i hate to admit to stealing from my own
family and then
it was you know going into stores and
stealing things panhandling
and my family was not happy about this i
dropped out of college my parents let me
home
100 times but then they said no we've
had it
we know what you're doing we don't like
it you don't you're not welcome on our
doorstep
don't don't come knocking we'll call the
police and i did come knocking
and they did call the police and so
i started catching minor cases um
never did too much time but to support
my habit to
to i had steal or panhandle i did
end up going to jail and so
that put me on the record you know now
now
the cops know me and i'm a homeless
person
in the san fernando valley uh
panhandling and hustling all day
every day for just one thing and that
that was dope
and it was it was a hard life um
i didn't see any foreseeable future
because
i was supposed to take over my dad's
business and that was down the drain
and so i had no real work experience so
i didn't know what to do with myself
and so i just thought okay
i'm just going to continue using but i
didn't want to be homeless so
many times you know i promise my parents
you know send me the treatment
help me out and you know i'll stop
forever
and i'd go into treatment for a week
start feeling sick and leave and i did
this
at least 100 times at least a hundred
times i'd go in and out of places
and so you know i my parents took me off
the
of their insurance you know and
so i didn't have blue cross i'd i had uh
medical so now i couldn't get into
real treatment centers nice like decent
places it was
places down here downtown like midnight
mission
and they didn't give you detox meds so
i just struggled and the parents
wouldn't let me home
and just it's just an
ongoing circle it's a it's a cycle
where are you staying today today i have
an
sro you do yeah so you're not in a tent
or anything like that
not anymore i i had to fight long and
hard for that
um you know i was on the street when
someone approached me
and said you can go to this place which
is called homeless health care
and they said just do what they tell you
and you'll end up with housing
so it's gonna be a lot better right yeah
it's a it's a lot better
it's harm reduction you know i'm still
struggling
but and i still go hungry sometimes but
my rent's 50 and you can't beat that
and that definitely helps with you know
i don't i don't use as hard anymore
um because of that it's a good thing
i think they're doing a really good
thing and i think they should definitely
keep on doing that to house more people
[Music]
and you still you're still using what
today i
i struggle with fentanyl um cocaine
methamphetamine and i'm on methadone
which which helps that's also harm
reduction
um but i i plan to stop all that stuff
if i can get off the methadone then it
gives me a better chance to get off
everything else because
it's it's a it's a bad influence when i
go to that any clinic
everyone out there is getting high i
plan
you know that day not to get high and
then someone pulls out a meth pipe
and you know says you want to hit and
there i go again and so it's
i have it's bad influences around me but
it's also
in my own mind like am i ready to get
off the stuff
because i struggle with extreme
depression and anxiety
and i feel like i need that stuff to
cope
and like what about getting a normal job
and just doing nine to five
and getting an apartment elsewhere like
i dreamed of
i would i would love to do that and i so
i do plan on getting off how
i guess one day at a time slowly i'd
like to go back to aaa
or n a and the pandemic kind of screwed
with that you know meetings were stopped
and i
you know didn't always have a phone to
go online and do zoom meetings
um but i'd like to get a sponsor
and and start fresh start new
and just do the right thing and just
make my social circle extremely small
well
two or three people that i know have my
back and who are sober
um like like my ex-girlfriend
uh she's doing it so i mean why can't i
so if i have just a few people in my
social circle
then i can start going to meetings again
and and just doing the right thing
but what have you learned from from all
of this how old are you i'm 34
34. what have you learned from all this
stuff um basically that
what my parents told me was right
and that it's a dog-eat-dog world and
i no one's gonna take care of me except
me
that i i have to work for what i want
and for what i need
and whichever way i choose to go the
good or the bad
i have to i have to do it myself no
one's going to give me a handout and say
here's a job
because out of pity no or here's money
out of pity that only works for so long
and what i've learned
is that i have to just pull myself up on
my bootstraps
and if i want to do something i just
gotta do it
and and commit to it and do it
like we were talking about working out
uh
if i want to have a six-pack i gotta do
sit-ups every day and have a good diet
and do a lot of cardio
but if i don't then i don't i won't do
that i won't do those things
so i gotta put in the footwork to
actually get to where i want to be
all right thank you so much for sharing
your story yeah and i wish you the best
of luck out there
thank you that's awesome thank you so
much
how'd i do that's great yeah
you